dass sich das in der wir leben man
negative pulsiert tag und nacht
der hamburger hafen kulturstätte
wirtschaftsmotor und sehnsucht wir
begleiten schweizer und schweizerinnen
die in der metropole am wasser leben und
arbeiten
mal mit dem strom man gegen den wind sie
alle sind an die elbe gekommen um hier
ihr glück zu finden
der hafen ist für sie weit mehr als ein
arbeitsplatz er ist abenteuer heimat und
hoffnung auf ein anderes leben dort oben
im norden thomas gisiger ist früh
unterwegs er hat heute viel zu tun dass
der schweizer einmal in hamburg landen
würde stand nicht auf dem plan
es ist weniger wichtig sind muss der
schweiz 2 das ist einfach passiert das
ist einfach alles passiert die auch dank
dass sie ja gar nicht
deutschland ist eben gesehen zog sie
nach hamburg zog aber dass das so schwer
zu machen
thomas leitet mit seinem partner das
kleine theater zweite heimat tun weit
des hafens die norddeutschen eigenheiten
nimmt er mit humor
schön lager schön es ist jetzt wieder
schön und aber mir ist ganz ehrlich
immer dass lily aber richtig gut aus
warendorf in hamburg schon ganz gut
einkaufen im hamburger hafen für sein
theater in dem er auch kocht das tor zur
welt bietet auch im feinkostladen ein
internationales sortiments
ich finde auch wenn man stress am tag
für das große programm hört man wenig
sieht man das auch ganz schön es auch
ist es mit schöne sachen umgibt violett
oder gabriel bleibt also immer in
normallage wunsch das einfach wieder so
frisch
[Musik]
spitze ab nein so ganz für mit timer
natur also heute vormittag ist es die
ganze und automatisch wenn die bws große
vielfalt vor dem schweizer kreuz einfach
ruf und und wie weiß nicht wie
automatisch mit sagte schmecken oder
wieder gute folie ist das ist schön und
die griffe für uns natürlich zum
schweizers auszumachen
der wahl-hamburger pflegt seine wurzeln
und investiert in die neue heimat
das theater verspricht event-charakter
nach der aufführung folgt ein drei gang
menü viel programm
da verliert auch thomas schon mal den
überblick
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
missverständnisse im alltag die
hamburger nehmen sie mit humor
anders wenn es ums geld geht in
deutschland gilt hamburgers teuer und
für thomas der hamburger hafen ist der
gigant des nordens rund 10.000 seeschiff
aus allen teilen der welt laufen ihm
jährlich an mehr als 130 millionen
tonnen waren werden hier pro jahr
umgeschlagen mit 7200 hektar umfasste
hafen ein zehntel des gesamten hamburger
stadtgebiet es für die schweiz ist der
hafen hamburg einer der wichtigsten
waren umschlagplätze jede woche bringen
36 güterzüge produkte aus aller welt gen
süden
die riesigen frachtschiffe brauchen im
hafen unterstützung um zu den terminals
zu kommen ohne hilfe können sie nicht
manövrieren so genannte schlepper ziehen
und schieben sie
[Musik]
kapitän timo müller steuert einen der
modernsten hafenschlepper der welt die
prager
ihr auftrag heute die chicago express
eines der größten containerschiffe der
welt sicher in den hafen zu manövrieren
für das anlegemanöver werden auch die
hafenlotsen aufgeboten
alle schiffe die lengers 90 meter sind
müssen auf der elbe und im hamburger
hafen einen lotsen an bord haben
die chicago express mit rund 5.000
containern an bord darunter auch ein aus
vietnam mit laufschuhen der firma on aus
der schweiz gps und elektronischen
seekarten können die erfahrenen
hafenlotsen nicht ersetzen
die männer kennen die
strömungsverhältnisse sowie die tiefe
und breite der fahrrinne so gut wie
niemand sonst
deshalb gehen sie an bord um das
kommando zu übernehmen und auch die
brake bringt sich in position per funk
weist ein lotse den schlepper vor das
schiff
[Musik]
viele gerne
jetzt ist höchste konzentration gefragt
warten auf das schleppseil
das hat die frage mit und gekommen nach
vorne doch erst maschine ausgeht da
haben wir natürlich ganz schlecht ich
kann also noch übrig dann irgendwann die
seite schnell zu fahren wenn eine
maschine und versuchen so schnell wie
möglich weg zu kommen
ich muss jetzt praktisch mal sehen dass
ich einen tick schneller oder genauso
schnell wieder schiff damit hand nicht
zu dicht mehr als hunderttausend tonnen
gewicht müssen zum ziel bewegt werden
und das schwierigste steht noch bevor
eine drehung vor dem terminal einst ein
großer industriestandort am hafen ist
der bezirk ottensen heute eine der
attraktivsten wohngegenden an der elbe
wo früher kleine handwerksbetriebe
metzger und düstere bars die engen
straßen säumten sind die mieten heute
rekordverdächtig ottensen ist dein szene
stadtteil hamburgs und mittendrin
saralisa schäuble sie kommen vor vier
jahren nach hamburg zunächst für ein
auslandssemester nach ihrem
studienabschluss zuges jedoch bald
wieder in den hohen norden
das ist für klick gemacht hat mit
homburg hat schon extrem viel mit dem
hamburger hafen einfach so im blick und
und also landschaft inszeniert weil es
ist eine strenge aber so radic wenn ich
nur mir vorher gehandelt automatisch es
ist wie so aufregend uns und sowohl sie
glücklich sehen also eine perfekte kombi
gehen wir augen für aber gerichtlich auf
der haid für so ganz am anfang
obwohl sarah lisa sofort gefallen an der
atmosphäre in der hafenstadt fand waren
die ersten jahre an der elbe hat seit
ihrer ankunft hält sie sich mit
verschiedenen jobs im hafenviertel über
wasser
diese sich durchkämpfen hat sie geprägt
vergisst was für eine person ich wurde
bindet das sich in der stadt bin und mir
sicher beschrieben oder sich ob die hand
durch machen
und plötzlich und ich bin sehr sprache
viele menschen plötzlich sind die
zweiräder einigen wochen hatte dachte
ich muss mir in seemannsknoten ging das
ohr tätowieren
damit komme wieder vergisst wer ich bin
und dass ich dann gemacht aber und das
ist ein rückschritt
saralisa hat ein ehrgeiziges ziel sie
will als journalistin in hamburg fuß
fassen
ausgerechnet in der norddeutschen
medienmetropole
drastisch höheren beruflichen selbst
vorgemacht haben wollen erfahren
werkzeuge bin wäre die ausbildung nicht
gemacht hat
zhw in winterthur es kann dann haben wir
ihn endlich vom land mit dem ausbilder
nötig hat was wir überhaupt gemacht
haben und ich denke es sollte jetzt ein
bachelor gemacht jetzt müssen wir
handeln job finden in deinem fall wo man
eigentlich studiert hatte aber den
journalismus ist halt wie krieg so dass
billiges einfach kein garant dafür dass
du noch an der stelle finden sollte mir
da gange solange sie noch nicht von
ihren honoraren als journalistin leben
kann sagt sarah lisa im hamburger hafen
die frau hedi ein beliebtes party
schäfer nennt landungsbrücken ist ihr
arbeitsplatz in einer stunde legt das
boot ab
[Musik]
der schwimmende club auf der elbe ist
eine feste konstante im hamburger
outdoor nachtleben
mein handy ist ziemlich knapp masse das
hat nach homer und von sofort rotiere
eigentlich das spezielle nicht auf den
chips war das mache ich natürlich
kollege frank fuchs schiff bringen und
am schluss von arbeit mit den weg
bringen und auch alle die ganze größe
die ganze technik sie ganz südbayern die
ganze instrument des mega viel mehr
aufwand wir haben alles startklar für
fenstertechnik los geht's
[Musik]
in wenigen minuten kommen die ersten
gäste nur einen steinwurf von der heli
entfernt steht das neue wahrzeichen der
hansestadt die elbphilharmonie
[Musik]
heute beginnen in der 11 wie die
hamburger ihr konzerthaus liebevoll
nennen vorbereitungen für ein
spektakuläres projekt im konzertsaal der
für seine akustik gerühmt wird
installieren bühnentechniker große
bildschirme in zusammenarbeit mit der
lichtkünstlerin rosalie wird das
philharmonische staatsorchester hamburg
mahlers achte neue umsetzen
eine inszenierung die unter
kunstexperten aus gewagt gilt noch weiß
keiner ob die installation in dieser
umgebung zur geltung kommen und
funktioniert während in der
elbphilharmonie die installation
aufgebaut wird tut sich auch in der
staatsoper besonderes
hinter beiden ideen steckt derselbe mann
der schweizer georges delnon seit zwei
jahren ist er der vorher in basel tätig
war
intendant der staatsoper hamburg so und
wir euch gesagt und auf den solisten
dass wir durchaus unterbrechen heute
abend also es gibt kein durchlauf in dem
sinne saal dunkel und der vorhang kommt
gemeinsam mit stardirigent kent nagano
hat jobs stellung immer wieder
ungewöhnliche projekte inszenierung
dieses mal der mozart klassiker die
zauberflöte als kita
[Musik]
die staatsoper realisierter stück mit
jugendlichen aus sozial schwachen
bezirken ja sagen wir mal es macht spaß
gerade im moment und ich finde hamburger
natürlich mit der app store und aufgang
nämlich und und seid natürlich sofort
der sofort der dynamik und interessiert
einfach gut und ich glaube man kann er
jetzt im moment so aufmerksamkeit und
das probieren nutzer wie ok
[Musik]
georges delnon und kent nagano wollen
die jugendlichen mit der musik kann
etwas heran führen mit denen diese
normalerweise nicht vermutet haben oper
und klassik
[Musik]
ähnlich überraschend ist ihr projekt in
der elbphilharmonie die große
lichtinstallation zur musik gustav
mahlers der fcz machen wir ja macht mit
der skulptur und das ist für mich alles
großes also bis umgeschaut immer sehr
beschäftigt hat schon in basel
musik und kunst zusammen zu bringen so
kunstwelt zusammenbringen und das ist
jetzt versucht oftmals 8 und da bin ich
selbst beantworten jetzt muss ich
stellen um die jugendlichen in der
staatsoper kümmern
am nachmittag will er in die elf um sich
zum ersten mal die installation der
bildschirm anzuschauen
ganz langsam bewegt sich die chicago
express durch den hamburger hafen eine
leine wird hinuntergeworfen um das
schleppseil hinauf zu ziehen
mit dem der container riese in den hafen
manövriert wird ein schlepper vorne
einer hinten die brake zieht der hintere
bremse
das frachtschiff wert kaum noch aus
eigener kraft schlepper und ms chicago
sind nun fix verbunden
das auge von unserer schleppleine setzt
auf dem schiff voller über geharkt und
jetzt besteht nicht nur die möglichkeit
mit unserer not slipanlage von dem
schiff wieder wegzukommen also wir haben
wir schon eine notlösung dann gibt die
bremse die winde frei dann rauscht die
ganze leider raus und wir können uns
praktisch wenn was ist vom schiff
entfernt
ansonsten gibt es keine andere
möglichkeit weil wir halten fest und
würden wir natürlich eine schleppleine
weil wir wissen dass sie im guten
zustand ist weil daran hängt natürlich
ist unser leben jetzt kommt die
schwierigste etappe der gesamten
einfahrt die 336 meter lange chicago
express muss durch eine der
kompliziertesten kurven der wasserwelt
bewegt werden
die einfahrt in die süderelbe
wasserstand wind und
strömungsverhältnisse müssen exakt
stimmen
es bleibt nur ein kleines zeitfenster
für die einfahrt
bis zu kümmern brücke ist ja ein riesen
bogen und den muss er halten würde ich
versuchen zu treffen links und rechts
wird flach
das sieht sehr gut aus
das schiff hat die kurve perfekt
genommen die nächste herausforderung
voll kurze zeit später der riesige
frachter muss unter der köhlbrandbrücke
durchfahren
mehr als 40 meter ist die tagespresse
nur bei niedrigem wasserstand pasta chef
problemlos unter dem bauwerk durch
als ganz kleiner steppke wein mit meinem
vater war der brücke wo die gebaut
worden ist und da steht man davor sagt
was für ein bauwerk so riesengroß rein
und fährt sich 50 jahre später passenden
die schiffe doch nicht mehr unter druck
das ist also enorm also 54 m
durchfahrtshöhe sie eigentlich auch
schon was aber die größten schiffs
einheiten passen halt je nach
ladezustand nicht mehr unter dieser
brücke durch kurz vor dem liegeplatz
musste chicago express auf den
zentimeter genau um die eigene achse
gedreht werden
auch diese arbeit übernehmen schlepper
und lotsen ablegen da hat auch dann
schon sehr schlepper festgemacht der
eine kommt doch eh
[Musik]
auch thomas ist wieder in bewegung
nur ein paar hundert meter vom hafen
entfernt hat er seine zweite heimat
gefunden
so lautet auch der name des theaters
dass thomas hier zusammen mit seinem
lebenspartner andreas betreibt
[Musik]
die zweite heimat ist restaurant und
theater zugleich jetzt mittag laufen die
vorbereitungen für die aufführung am
abend thomas ist gelernter dekorations
gestalter inneneinrichtung und
bühnenbild hat er selbst entworfen war
natürlich für stück aus der schweiz aber
nicht so dass man aus reifen ist so
extrem wenig platz und das bürgerbüro
musiker hat aber letztendlich das mache
ich natürlich auch spezielle familie
ganz ehrlich ohne woods viele im stück
stoff deponie und die punkte am stück
rock und sowohl für lineare und so
schöner
die gäste sollen sich in der zweiten
heimat wie zu hause fühlen
seine stücke haben immer einen schweizer
bezug thomas sieht sich dabei als
vermittler zwischen den kulturen und er
verbindet norddeutsche und schweizer
tradition auch beim essen wird sie und
mahlzeit das ist übrigens nur von meiner
autos stück das ist der titel vom auto
stück vor schweiz und deutschland
aufeinander trifft und turnhalle der st
johannes reben einfach so dass man sich
immer wieder bewusst wird dass das
mahlzeit deutschland ist und kuriert
sich potter spitzenpolitiker also
schweizer begriffe wie rabatte und klatt
von cree und hoeneß muss überlegt und
little ist
also ich versteh jochen schweizer
botschaften das labor wurde der rhythmus
bringen in deutschland sag ich mal so
aber hätte ich ganz ehrlich auto mit
heimweh bewältigung und seehofer hätten
schon ihr rezept drin und dann machen
wir jetzt so wie es absolut unpassend
es geht nämlich ries kasimir und das ist
könnte die schweizer jeder sowieso und
ich mache immer jesus familienmutter die
soli engagiert aber ganz viel mit heimat
store
[Musik]
wenig später an brücke 10 im hamburger
hafen
die letzten gäste gehen an bord des
musik schiffs frau hedi maximal 91
personen haben auf dem dampfer platz
inklusiv aller schweizer tresen frau
sarah lisa und band
[Musik]
zusammen getrennt spezielle athletisch
also setzte ich mich jetzt da so was ich
dass man jetzt sogar die maus aber ein
halber meter und alles ist ganz fest
verbunden damit sich bewegen also zum
beispiel frank weise getränke sondern
wir sind halt auch pragmatisch 15
beatrice drauf und machen alles wie
immer gab
und wenn ich nach einem spiel gegen wir
servieren
die route ist jeden tag eine andere
immer abseits der klassischen
hafenrundfahrten heute geht's zu den
werften lagerumschlag plätzen und an den
kränen der terminals vorbei für sarah
lisa ist die edi weit mehr als ein
originelles stück st pauli lebt reist
und so eine bootsfahrt im mittelstand
ist für mich sehr emotional von sarah
lisa liebt den job auf der kult barkasse
noch immer auch jemand frank hat hier
früher als bootsmann gearbeitet
selbst der manchmal etwas raue tun hier
oben
ist ihr inzwischen ans herz gewachsen
wir lebten in hamburg eine tanzshow
andreas roth cdu kämpfen
wenn man sich das plötzlich tresen oder
es passiert ist es halt der satz ich
krieg zwei bier oder zwei cola oder was
aber diese so ich kriege ich selber hab
ne böse gemeint sondern sich einfach so
wie mir das da sagt man du hast in
zürich live
dann wird die rückfahrt an und wird seit
ich hätte gerne bitteschön und die
formulierung sind ganz andere was aber
jetzt sage sie zum sondertarif finden
aber mittlerweile schätze das sehr
ja sowieso ganz klar und auch mit woche
also trockener humor was wird jetzt
einfach sehr entspricht
heute sollte eine italienische wenn für
ausgelassene stimmung
[Musik]
und weil sarah lisa das wasser so lief
lässt sie sich hier auch immer wieder
für ihre reportagen inspirieren
zurzeit arbeitet sie an einem artikel
zum paddeln auf hamburgs wasserstraßen
[Musik]
auch wenn es scheint das hätte die
elbphilharmonie die hauptkirche sankt
michaelis als wahrzeichen hamburgs
abgelöst drunter michel mit seinen 132
meter hohen kirchturm war immer stolz
über dem hafen
[Musik]
am fuße des imposanten traums
seemannsmission kein kampf lebt kapitän
jörg niklaus aus der schweiz
[Musik]
ein orkan fegte kennt sie alle
derzeit werden kommen neue post habe die
kommen aus dem rasen da ist es ganz
anderes klima schon ein halbes
jahrhundert ist der zur see gefahren
seit zwei jahren ist ein kleines
mutiertes thema sein zuhause
[Musik]
das einfach nicht angewendet und fertig
kriegst du schickst alle viele gute
leute die einem da dem sagen und
schwester in einem drittel ist wenn ihr
die ganze wohnung sei blickte dann am 18
das ist vorbei also das ist gut so
witzig einfach dieses einfache das passt
schon
also je tonne ist absolut perfekt und
das ist so noch zu allem nur in hamburg
der 73 jährige kapitän gehört zu den
rund 25.000 gästen im haus
es ist ein kleiner multikulti kosmos der
den seeleuten eigentlich nur als heimat
auf zeit dienen sollte jack nicklaus es
geblieben
zu den wenigen mitarbeitern hat er ein
herzliches verhältnis
schließlich sind sie eine art
familienersatz
an allen grenzen
fischedick heute die chicago express ist
mit ihrer fracht und und container für
die schweiz fast am ziel aber es wird
noch eine stunde dauern bis das schiff
fest vertäut an der kaimauer liegt
vorher müssen die schlepper den riesigen
frachter um die eigene achse drehen
[Musik]
wir ziehen jetzt ein bisschen praktisch
zonen ist und dann treten wir über
steuerbord hier in dem dreh kreis und
dann fahren wir dann vorwärts zum
liegeplatz
heide backbord mit sechseinhalb 1000ps
ziehen wir jetzt 74 tonnen mit 74.000
wieder stärkt sich lieber der flotte und
die 180 grad drehung klappt auf den
meter genau bevor die chicagoer kaimauer
anlegen kann muss ein anderes schiff
platz machen
im hafen gibt es keinen stillstand alle
zeitabläufe sind minuten genau
aufeinander abgestimmt
zeit ist geld
es heißt leinen los für den schlepper
von timo möller
ein letzter kraftakt steht noch an
wir drücken das schön jetzt dran und
wenn der stifter zu dicht dran ist dann
haben wir die möglichkeit mit dem kopf
das schiff wieder abzuziehen
und wir wir an der bordwand weiße
markierung
das war keine frage und vor karte links
an diesen weißen markierungen ist die
importwaren verstärkt und dann wieder
drücken können
das können wir nicht an jeder stelle
ansonsten drücken wir den ball rein
währenddessen bremst der zweite
schlepper das schiff beim anlegen damit
es nicht gegen die kaimauer preis an
land übernehmen die sogenannten
festmacher die schweren tore
erst wenn das schiff fest vertäut ist
kann der container riesen nicht mehr
abdriften
die heizzentrale für die frage wir sind
fertig die chicago express ist nach
zweieinhalb monaten im hafen hamburg
angekommen
[Musik]
wer lange zur see gefahren ist kann sich
ein leben und wasser schiff und seeluft
häufig nicht mehr vorstellen
so geht es auch kapitän jack nicklaus
vor einem jahr hatte er versucht in der
schweiz sesshaft zu werden
aber auf dem weg richtung süden kehrte
er um
das seemannsheim war sein zufluchtsort
[Musik]
mikros sichel sofort auf seemannsheim
will durch definierte aus der
fahrradfahrer die nägel und so und das
ist ganz wichtig also wie sie ja sowieso
ganz spezielle spezielles team sauerland
wichtig sprache nicht zwischen
alemannisch zwischen oder so und er hat
viele frage und blues klassenfahrt
sie sagt mir du vom deckt nun bis zum
cup teil und so schon gute sache
die scheine aus walnüssen und niklas
tochter und enkelkinder leben in der
schweiz
wer telefoniert regelmäßig mit ihnen
gelegentlich besucht er sie auch obwohl
er sich im hafen hamburg wohl fühlt
plagt ihn mitunter die sehnsucht und
auch der gedanke daran wo er begraben
sein will beschäftigt ihn ja ja wenn
heimat scheint an ihr liegt aber da ist
und sich schon mal zum tragen hier
grösser oder gleich zum abstellort dabei
schon echt ne bärtige tief vormonat
offen seemann es gab hier in hamburg ist
offen friedhof ja dass schiffe
grabsteine da jemand wird schon eifrig
geübt und so dass er in der maßgeblich
zu mir leid wenn ich schon nie geheime
pixi wenn die letzten atemzüge risiko
und wurde heimatstadt ich also die das
gibt es ja schon aber erst werden wir
als ein komischer aber wenn es nicht
darum was die jaaa unglück filippo wie
vor dass es da ich aber noch nicht
erfolgt
mit den unwägbarkeiten der weltmeere
konnte jürgen clauß umgehen das
geregelte leben an land hingegen
überfordert ihn mitunter zurück in der
elbphilharmonie nur wenige hundert meter
vom seemannsheim entfernt mittlerweile
ist es abend der saal ist bereit für die
erste probe der streicher von mahlers
achter mit der neuen lichtinstallation
das bauwerk der schweizer architekten
herzog & de meuron ist bekannt für seine
spezielle akustik 300 mitwirkende
musiker und sänger sollen den großen
konzertsaal der elfe mit ihren tönen
ausfüllen
doch die neue lichtinstallation ist für
manche musiker aus dem orchester
irritierend hier machen wir jetzt schon
an allerdings nicht immer eins zu eins
das was auch zunehmend noten 105 sehr
viel bewegt hat ist als die musik oder
umgekehrt auch für dirigent kent nagano
ist die situation neu bewerten zweiter
teil 1
während dem saal schon geprobt wird ist
georges delnon noch auf dem weg zur
elbphilharmonie
der anblick des neuen konzerthauses
überwältigte ihn jedes mal aufs neue
der erste blick auf die eltern nie hätte
nicht so sensationell geradeaus kontrast
zu der alte architektur hier hoffen so
und es ist wie eine vision morgen
plötzlich sicht also ihr lieblings
entdeckt plötzlich ganz anders der haufe
und sie immer ganz andere event
verhalten ist entweder tisches ruhig und
nachher hier blast ein wind das ist ein
richtig falsch verknüpften toppen
umgekehrt wie jetzt viel wind und hier
ist fast windstill es ist viel aber das
ist das ist für mich irgendwie so
spannende erfahrung will
das ist aber ich hoffe natürlich saison
erwähnt der stadt
und genau genommen und fans völlig kann
besonders
naja so noble garten selbst natürlich
medien arabische schrift werde
[Musik]
in thomas theater der zweiten heimat
treffen die ersten gäste ein
[Musik]
thomas macht sich bereit für den
auftritt gegen das scheinwerferlicht in
seinem ein mann stück wird er solo durch
den abend führen
einzig dem messestand der jungen scheiße
der text vergaß es ist wirklich jedes
mal eins oder sich so eine panikattacke
an eben weil jedes morgen weg gemacht
dass ich dem unternehmen dank wurde und
wenn ihr nicht dekorations gestaltete
bleiben jedes mal jedes mal und immer
wieder machen ok-chef minute entscheides
nico hat es mich nach fünf minuten
guten abend meine damen und herren
mein name ist ueli haldimann und ich
freue mich sehr dass sie heute abend
meine geschichte hören möchten
in der elbphilharmonie nutzt schorsch
denn nun den bühneneingang fernab von
den touristenmassen die sich am gebäude
tummeln
sind open house hier sind die real
barrieren
das hat mich schon drin der rezeption
sowie wien
der weg zum konzertsaal den herzstück
der elbphilharmonie führt über großzügig
gestaltete treppen und zugänge es läuft
eigentlich durchblick unglaublich toll
dass es gar nicht im detail ein anderer
ist holen und so und diese ganze kba
also so großartig und da ja ich finde
sie einfach auf
jetzt nämlich stehen sie ist können wir
die arena
die steuer schon diese stelle stehe der
wahnsinnig ist großartig
wow
[Musik]
kent nagano guckt heute mit den
streichern alleine
der test mit der lichtinstallation steht
morgen an ohne orchester vorstellung
kann nur hoffen dass alles funktionieren
wird
er zieht sich zurück an einem ganz
besonderen ort ein fenster im
backstage-bereich im zwölften stock
oberhalb des pulsierenden hafen lebens
des lieblings plötzlich ihr wille ist
cafeteria hier treffen sie vor der pause
vom konzert oder danach
deswegen ist das bild ja das ist
letztlich wie unterhose und ist
natürlich unglaublich schöne schönen
blick
[Musik]
schau ins tal und den kuli du bist der
glücklichste mensch der welt
[Applaus]
lassen sie uns gemeinsam 2
vorhang auf für den zweiten akt im
thomas theater vom schauspieler zum koch
thomas hat noch lange nicht feierabend
aus dem speisesaal erreichen thomas
spontane sonderwünsche der gäste
herrlich okay da müssen gucken und noch
vegetarisch essen kam was man noch
aufhängen kann in kleinen team packt
jeder mit an
thomas partner andreas übernimmt den
service
so
wir haben es gleich
mir ist diese auch loslegen na ja es
wird zeit zur wind kann ich allein ich
brauche keine hilfe basilikum die
physalis und die mandeln und
schauspiel-kollegen aussage das führte
wir machen ja wort applaus wachsen
theaters biertrinken fertig aber stimmt
schon ich natürlich schon ein doppelter
erfolg sagt ja das ist ständig
[Musik]
während den theater der abend ausklingt
wird auf der anderen seite der elbe
weiter unter hochdruck gearbeitet
das be und entladen der chicago express
ist in vollem gange und wird die ganze
nacht hindurch weiter gehen
der hamburger hafen schläft nie in der
nächsten folge recherchiert saralisa zum
thema paddeln auch hamburgs
wasserstraßen jobs dennoch ist
angespannt die premiere in der
elbphilharmonie steht an
thomas gisiger entwickelt ein neues
bühnenstück zum thema kreuzfahrt und in
hoch technologisierten hafen wetter
container für die schweiz auf die bahn
verfrachtet